[Music]
we're going to begin though with a major
shift in power on Capitol Hill CBS News
can now project the Republican party has
indeed secured the 218 seats needed to
win the majority in the house even
though a number of races still have not
been called yet and today current
Speaker Nancy Pelosi is expected to make
an announcement about her future plans
Nicole Killian is on Capitol Hill
following all of this Nicole everybody
wants to know what is Nancy Pelosi going
to do good morning to you hey good
morning yeah it's a big question that
will potentially be answered soon but
make no mistake there will be divided
government here in congress with
Republicans now in charge of the house
and Democrats in control of the Senate
minority leader Kevin McCarthy who has
been nominated to serve as house Speaker
declared it is official Democrats one
party rule is over GOP Party leaders
have vowed that oversight of the Biden
Administration will be at the top of
their agenda including the withdrawal
from Afghanistan and Hunter Biden's
overseas business dealings they also
plan to look into the origins of covet
McCarthy will have to contend with a
smaller than expected Republican
majority and a fractured conference
several hard-line conservatives have
proposed rule changes that would chip
away at his leadership but McCarthy
believes he will secure the votes he
needs to become speaker in January
Democrats also have decisions to make
now that they will be in the minority
speaker Nancy Pelosi has not said
whether she will remain in leadership
but her office posted that the speaker
plans to address her future plans today
the speaker has said that that home
invasion attack on her husband will
affect her decision Gail yeah we're all
waiting to hear but Nicole the Democrats
are saying we got to get some stuff done
we're hearing that the Senate moved
forward with key pieces of legislation
just yesterday that they say they need
to get through before Democrats lose a
house what can you tell us about that
yeah well that's right well protections
for same-sex and interracial marriages
could soon be cut certified into federal
law after the legislation cleared a key
procedural hurdle in the Senate
Wednesday 12 Republicans joined the
entire Democratic caucus in voting to
move the bill forward Democrats have
warned since the Supreme Court
overturned Roe versus Wade in June that
Federal protections for such marriages
could be at risk President Biden
welcomed the vote and urged Congress to
send the bill to his desk lawmakers are
also hoping to pass and elections Reform
Bill that would prevent future
presidential candidates from obstructing
the electoral vote process Gail all
right Nicole thank you very much